Bonjour curieuses et curieux,
Aujourd'hui je vais faire appel
à vos plus mauvais  souvenirs de vie en société.
Les mouvements de foule : donc au choix,
les gens qui poussent le matin pour
essayer de rentrer dans le métro,
la sortie de votre concert électro
préféré,
ou la ruée vers la nouvelle caisse de supermarché qui vient d'ouvrir.
Et bien sachez que tous ces phénomènes
ressemblent à ça :
Des chercheurs de la
région parisienne se sont intéressés
à la modélisation mathématique des
mouvements de foule.
Le principe de base est assez simple :
Imaginez que la foule se comporte
comme  un ensemble de grains en mouvement
un peu comme ce qui se passe dans un sablier.
Avant de commencer il faut
établir un certain nombre de règles :
Si on représente les hommes par des
boules....
si on représente les individus par des disques,
et qu'on étudie leur position, toutes les configurations ne seront pas permises.
Les boules ou les disques ne pourront prendre
qu'un certain nombre de
trajectoires pour se ruer vers la sortie.
Pour modéliser mathématiquement une
foule,
la première contrainte que les boules
doivent respecter
est évidemment l'interdiction de se recouvrir l'une l'autre.
Les boules peuvent entrer en contact, ce
qui est représenté ici par des traits
mais elle ne se chevauchent pas.
Non, pas de ça chez nous, on ne se chevauche pas !
On suppose également que les personnes
connaissent les lieux.
Chaque boule est donc individuellement capable de déterminer sa trajectoire optimale,
c'est à dire le chemin le plus court
vers la sortie, en évitant les obstacles.
Dans cette simulation, plus les boules sont rouges,
plus elles sont comprimées.
Ces contraintes limitent donc les mouvements
à un certain nombre de possibilités que
l'on peu formaliser mathématiquement.
On peut alors définir l'insatisfaction
de chaque individu
comme la distance lui restant à parcourir
pour atteindre la porte.
Plus il est loin, plus son insatisfaction est grande.
L'évacuation de la foule consiste donc à minimiser l'insatisfaction globale,
qui est la somme des insatisfactions de chacun des individus.
Cet ensemble d'individus peut également être décrit macroscopiquement
c'est à dire qu'on peut le considérer comme une entité
dont l'évolution est semblable à
celle d'un fluide.
Certaines situations donnent des résultats comparables,
que l'on utilise une description microscopique
ou macroscopique de la foule.
C'est le cas par exemple pour cette
modélisation d'un groupe de personnes
qui sort du métro pour se diriger vers
un escalator.
Peut-être d'ailleurs que c'est une situation désagréable que vous avez déjà vécu.
Cependant si l'on regarde dans le détail,
certains effets ne sont décrits que par une modélisation microscopique.
C'est le cas notamment de l'effet que les chercheurs ont appelé
"Faster is Slower"
Quel accent !
Parfois, lorsque toutes les personnes poussent pour atteindre la sortie,
on arrive à un blocage.
Et ce qui peut sembler paradoxal,
c'est que plus on cherche à sortir rapidement,
plus cette situation se produit.
En gros, plus on veut aller vite,
plus on pousse et plus ça bloque.
D'où le nom de Faster is Slower.
Oui, parce que Fast and Furious, cétait déjà pris...
Les mathématiciens ont alors introduit
une composante psychologique
dans le comportement des individus.
La foule devient sentimentale !
... soif d'idéal...
L'idée est donc de forcer certaines boules à arrêter de pousser
pour libérer le blocage.
Sur cette image la foule est bloquée.
Les flèches correspondent à la vitesse
souhaitée par chacune des boules si elles
étaient seules.
A ce stade les chercheurs imposent
que la vitesse souhaitée d'une
boule diminue
lorsqu'elle est bloquée pendant un certain temps.
Cela revient à dire qu'un individu
arrete de pousser quand ça n'avance pas.
C'est de la courtoisie.
C'est donc la courtoisie qui permet de
débloquer la situation
dans cette vidéo de boules.
Enfin les mathématiciens ont
retrouvé dans leur modèle
un effet surprenant et déjà observé et utilisé en architecture :
La présence d'un obstacle en amont de la sortie
rend l'évacuation plus rapide.
Voilà, donc, même avec une description
assez limitée du comportement humain,
cette modélisation mathématique permet
de reproduire de nombreux phénomènes
observés lors des mouvements de foule
y compris certains effets paradoxaux.
Sur ce, c'est la fin de l'épisode
et j'en ai la boule au ventre.
Je vous laisse admirer ce que serait la
sortie d'une salle d'exposition
avec des individus courtois
et respectant  une distance entre eux.
Ici pas de foule contact !
Emportés par la foule qui nous traîne, nous entraîne...
N'hésitez pas à vous abonner
et allez faire un tour sur la
chaîne du CNRS,
où vous trouverez d'autres contenus scientifiques, plus
journalistiques et documentaires.
Abonnez-vous !